if I showed up to a job to fix a house
and I opened my toolbag and all I have
is a
hammer and all they have to hang the
drywall with is
screws and so I do this job with
hammering screws through
drywall it will be loose and not
straight what I say I did a great job no
can I say I did the best job with the
tool I had
yes did I fail no No in fact I may have
accomplished something pretty
significant I hung drywall with a
hammer okay that's pretty dang
impressive I'm not a failure what I do
need though is new tools and new
training and I'm probably going to have
to redo that
garage but I did a pretty impressive job
with a
hammer you my friend have to stop
referring to yourself as a failure every
time you don't get something right